so hi everyone I'm Jeremy and today
we're going to look at some examples of
interactive visualizations built with
pics ejs and GPIO widgets but don't
worry there won't be too much of
JavaScript so you can find me on on
Twitter on github and also can have a
look at my website for similar projects
but first of all it's good to just stop
for a while and look at what we have
when we want to make visualizations in
Python so there is already a lot of
tools a lot of frameworks and as you can
see here on the map they are actually
clustered in different categories so if
you are in that part so on the right
side there is more about using tools
with a an API close to Madrid clip but
for us in our case we'll be looking more
at the red cluster so that's the
JavaScript cluster so this map was
presented by Jaguar no class at PyCon
2017 and it's a good reference to know
where to start when we want to make
visualizations but for us it would be
more like going really in a niche case
so using a library that is not even
shown on this map for very very specific
use cases all right so the motivation
basically is to not have what you have
on left but what you have on the right
so really like something not like
typical bar chart or typical scatter
plots but more something like
interactive and moving and maybe just
simple shapes such as squares and
circles alright so first of all Jupiter
lappy suggests and trippy widgets might
be a lot to take in at once but Jupiter
lab if you are not using it yet this is
basically what you're seeing right now
in a browser so it's the next generation
UI for GPU notebooks so I really
encourage you to try it out if you
haven't done so yet it adds a bunch of
features for support files power here
you can look at your files you can
integrate it with a lot of extensions
you can even have terminal and split
windows and everything we look at it a
bit later all right pixie j/s it's a
powerful 2d rendering engine written in
JavaScript so it's made for the web and
it's an abstraction on top of
canvas and WebGL so we don't have to
deal with too much with all of the
internals of WebGL and how it works but
instead we can just use an API there is
a slightly slimport to to use as an end
user so here we have an example this is
basically canvas with a blue background
and a bunny in the middle of the screen
rotating so how do we do this this is
just as simple as creating an
application a pixie application writing
the sprite for the bunny putting it in
the middle of the screen and then in
pixie dress there's not this notion of
ticker which is basically a function
that will be called at each frame and
here at for each frame we just rotate we
add a ribbit of Delta to the rotation
all right finally GPIO widgets is a
framework for building interaction
interactively relation in a browser so
it's even more than that actually it's
just a framework to make it easy to sync
data between the kernel and the fronton
so when you use a Jupiter notebook you
have a daikon which is a kernel it can
be in Python it can be in other language
but in our case it will be in Python and
you have a front end which is a mix of
javascript and HTML and here in for the
trippy widgets framework
the idea is you create an object on the
Python side and then there will be a
counterpart object created on the other
side and then you can start modifying
some attributes and the values on the
Python zone and it will be automatically
synced with the front-end and you can do
the same the other way around so I think
it would be better to just look at an
example so here we have the I PI widgets
library which is the official widgets
library built for Python and we're going
to create an insulator that goes from 0
to 10 so we can interact with it right
now but we can also ask the notebook to
show a second view for the same widget
so there we go so we have the same view
for this for the object we created using
the in slider and we are basically in
that scenario where we have two views
for the same object and then we can
access the value of that object in
and we can also set it and it gets
automatically synced between the back
end and the front end right you can
create your own there's a really good
tutorial on the official documentation
and of course there are already some
libraries built on top of that and very
mature
so the cupid for example is using d3.js
on the front end to make this kind of
interactive visualizations there is a
pirate flag for displaying maps in a
browser there is also a PI volume to
show 3d contents in a browser so it's
built on top of 3GS but for us we're
back to this little animation style so
how do we do we display something in a
notebook like this all right so first of
all let's look at what we have here so
this ipod is packaged is basically just
running on this machine this is a local
Python package just standard and it
exposes this simple shaped class so
let's look at the implementation of this
class quick very quickly so you can see
that incinerating from this damu jet
which comes from this ipad Widgit and
here we have a bunch of metadata for the
widgets communication and here we have a
flag user-defined flag for enabling or
disabling a feature I will just see what
it looks like afterwards and here let's
put it on the side all right so that is
on the right that is the the front-end
part of this widget so we have a model
here which also comes from the GPO
widgets library so it's we extend this
base model and then we can add our
everything we want to be synced between
the two the two parts and then we have
the view and the view is basically where
the Big C application will be created so
we create the pixi application there and
similar to the bunny thing we saw just
before we create the graphics then we
can call some line style then we finally
draw our rectangle in the middle we
position the shape the center of the
screen and then we have the ticker back
and we are this is where we read the
rotate flag which is defined here and
the pipes on side and whenever we rotate
with change rotation so similar to the
Baniya example but this is created from
from scratch using the iPad which at
library and when we when we finally make
use of this so let's close this panel
and yeah so in internship the Python
object and we asked a notebook to
displayed for us so we get our square in
the middle similar to the bunny and then
we can activate this flag and we get it
rotating because this is what we
implemented in a pixie application right
so building on top of this so the entire
presentation will be just starting from
this little example and try to make a
bit more elaborated use cases building
on top of this we can just say okay draw
me a hundred shapes in that case it's
circles we can make sure that is
actually a circle by just asking Python
to give us the value for this shape
attribute but we can change it here and
it gets propagated to the front end so
it's zoom out a little bit yeah and
similar to what we saw before we can
just start in being flags we can also
add another one a wobot flag where we
get whatever user-defined behavior we
want to implement and yeah so I hope you
got the idea of the intent of this kind
of visualization so that we can start
looking at something a bit more
elaborate in May and also maybe a bit
more useful so in our case we start
looking at a puzzle so this is a puzzle
a wooden puzzle and there are 16
triangles and the goal is to put them
all in in a big one and there is one
constraint is that the corals need to
match so for example if you look at the
one at the bottom right here we have
black matching with black and green
matching with green and then we have to
continue adding all of the other
triangles so that there is no conflict
of course basically so of course you can
stop playing with this like this like if
you have the toy puzzle with you just
try to make your way and see if you can
find solution but you can also go the
the other the other routes and try to
solve it programmatically and since we
are in notebook since
using PCGS we can also make use of all
of these tools and just build on top of
them to draw a visualization right in
the browser because you might want to
solve this puzzle chromatically but then
without the visualization it can be hard
to know whether you actually found the
solution or not when we have this kind
of really visual problems it's much
nicer to have something like the direct
feedback in a browser so let's look at
what we have here so to spare you the
details of implementing a visualization
for this this is all encapsulated in
this widget so the widget was built
following the same style as the previous
example but we can just use it right
here in a browser so what we see we get
our canvas we get our six triangles
aligned on the right and then we have
all of the colors everything and we also
have additional controls and those
controls come from the iPad widgets
library so the cool thing with the whole
jupiter widget framework is we can reuse
a lot of stuff and we can connect them
together so we will see later what
happens when we click on buttons so the
idea is you can add some kind of hooks
and then whenever you click on the
button you can trigger an action on the
canvas all right
so what can we do with this widget the
idea is to also be able to visualize
animations so be able to visualize
transitions between states so like we
stopped playing with with the toy in
real life we start placing triangles and
we would add a new one but it would be
cool if we could see those triangles
moving around and see what's happening
under the hood when we start solving
such a problem all right so in our case
a state is basically just a list of 16
elements corresponding to the 16
triangles here we have a triangle number
13 zoom a little bit triangle number 13
with rotation one at the first position
and here we have another one the number
12 with rotation zero so rotation is
encoded as a anything so from 0 to 2 0 1
2 to show whether we are rotating the
triangle or not all right so now we have
a model for the state and we can see how
we can use it in our little little
widget so here we pass
a bunch of tests states so we have here
empty and these days so there's nothing
and then we start placing triangle seven
we rotate it one time all rotated two
times then we add a triangle zero we
rotate it again and then we bring
everything on the board and we were to
rotate everything one time to the to the
left and this is how it looks like so
this is time to make use of this little
controls so maybe it's time to make it
slower all right so we have our triangle
number seven brought on the board
rotating three times and then we have
number zero that we bring rotate one
time and then we bring everything at
once and we rotate everything at once if
we don't want to do we already smelly we
just click the play button and this
thing will be looping all the time and
if we are bored we can also speed it up
so it goes faster and then we also have
extra buttons such as start and end to
go from the big to the beginning to the
end and and so on all right
or use this little slider here to go a
specific position in this list of states
all right so that's our tool that's what
we have now we are finally ready to
solve the puzzle in Python so the idea
again is to really not touch JavaScript
at all and just have the interface in
Python so that we can actually implement
the algorithm there in a notebook and
let the visualization do the job of
showing us feedback all right so here is
an interface and you can see here this
is the sort method that is not
implemented and that we're going to
implement we can make use of the loc
method which is basically just taking a
snapshot of a current state that we can
append to this big list and then
visualize later and there is also this
fun method which is going to check all
of the triangles whether they have any
conflict in terms of colors or not and
here is basically we are checking for
all of them that they are they are
actually good so is valid might be a
really tricky to define this one first
Ribit tricky to understand what it means
so it's taking an integer I that
corresponds to the position of a
triangle to track between 0 and 15
inclusive
it's returning a boolean which would be
true if the triangle at position I
doesn't have any conflict of colors
otherwise it would return force and if
we look at this example here for
triangle number seven we see that right
is matching with red but black is not
matching with white so it's going to
return false and we can make use of this
API that which define in a widget itself
so that the person consuming the widget
can reason about the problem in a much
easier way all right so first try why
not just randomly sample the whole board
and see what happens so 200 times take a
random permutation of the board and then
take a snapshot so the Queen visualized
it check if it's found if it's found
then we just say okay we stop and we can
execute this unfortunately we don't
didn't see our little print which means
that we didn't find the solution and
which is expected because just searching
randomly like this doesn't bring us
anywhere so yeah it's just a little
warm-up to be able to play with this
widget so we can continue like this 200
times but we can also spare the pain and
go directly to the end and of course it
doesn't match but at least we have a
very direct feedback we know oh this is
wrong and we can move on all right so
now we're going to look at a better
implementation so in our case we'll be
using a brute force approach so by just
recursively placing all the triangles
one by one and then when there is one it
doesn't match anymore we just remove it
from the pot so the typical recursive
problem and here the method for that is
it's called place and it's taking the
position of the triangle we want to
place at that time and in the recursive
approach there is always a base case in
our case it would be whether we have
placed off the triangles or not if they
are all on the ball it means that we
managed to place them all without any
conflict divorce we missed it we finally
found the solution otherwise we have to
go through all of the other triangles
are left check whether they are used or
not if they'll use we skip if they are
not use which was mock that moms used
and then we go through all of the
rotation this is where we take the
snapshot to be able to visualize what's
happening when we rotate the triangles
and then we finally make use of our
little is valid function for that
particular triangle and if this one is
doing
this is valid then we can continue and
recurse one more time by checking
triangle number I plus one all right and
if none of this works then it's time to
undo the thing and also take snapshot
there so let's run this and run this
okay what we get is we here we found a
solution and also ten thousand steps so
take a long time to look at all of this
stuff I'm King but we won't be looking
at one by one so we can just display it
again with the same widget and start
yeah going through the entire thing here
so let's slow it down a little bit maybe
bit more alright so as you can see here
we go just go from in the list we just
place them one by one and there here
we're looking for white and blue
we found one we just leave it on the
board where we're looking for a red
color we also found one we leave it
there and so on and the idea is to is to
see when we implement such a thing what
happens so you can move move on and see
for sample iteration number 100 3700 so
it's looking good it's looking good but
we still haven't 9000 left so it means
that at some point there is some
backtracking involved because one of the
previous choices was wrong and we have
to go back to to the beginning in some
way but we can just let it play on its
own and see what happens ah it's the end
yeah so and now in seconds we finally
have our answer and yeah
we can double check all of the single
course one by one but that's it that's
the solution and we don't have to just
check one by a like we will get an array
instead of numbers it would be much much
harder to know whether we have find a
found a solution or not so that's
basically it and this example has more
details if you look at this article
there so it's also using a different
library so p5.js which is similar to
pick CJ s but oh yeah so if you're
interested in also how to create the
JavaScript part of visualizations and
you can check out the code on github you
can also run it on binder without having
to install anything on your laptop but
now let's go back to let's put in you
with something even more elaborated
so
let's talk about games a little bit and
how to view states of games all right so
the game we are going to talk about is
called Prospero and it's developed at
Google where I'm currently working at
and it's a hidden object game it's
available on Android on iOS and also on
Facebook as a WebGL game alright and it
looks like this so this is the core core
game so it's a hidden object games it
means that you get a list of items of
objects you have to find in the scene
and faster you find them the more
bonuses you get the more points you get
and then you can use two points and
bonuses to buy items that you can place
on your island so the main character has
an island which is actually yours and
then you can start placing buildings
decorations and so on you can buy cash
you can use your coins and so on so in
our case is this game a player has a
progression so how far in the story the
player is but there is also a
representation of this island for the
photo player and this is basically just
a JSON file so it's stored like that
like a bunch of metadata for all of the
items and sometimes what we get is
requests from players because they left
the device to their kids and the kids
they just started to play with the game
and deleted every single item and then
they ask us can you please restore my
game state as it was two weeks ago or so
and we have a tool like this for
customer care and they can use it to
actually check the state of a player at
a given time and then help the players
to go back to where they were before so
this is a tool written in pixie J's
and it's also running in a web browser
and it was offered by a colleague of
mine Benedict also working at Google and
basically have I don't even know how
this thing works inside but it doesn't
really matter because here what I would
like to show is how we can actually make
use of the same tool which was which is
used here in by customer care but in a
different context and in this context
would be JP Renaud book all right so
under goal for that I mean why would we
want to have access to such a widget
well once we
previous state in JSON we can start
playing with the previous state itself
using Python and this is what I will
show you right now so let's look at a
clear state first so this is a list of
objects or dictionaries where we have x
and y to show the position of the item
on the island and we also have the type
of item that is at this particular
position all right
and this is our widget and we can create
a widget here and we can set the state
that we just displayed before and we can
just ask the notebook to show the widget
for us so we get our widget here and
this corresponds to the state we saw
before and since it's exactly the same
tool we can just use the exact same
features so we can zoom and hover on
that and just explore a state of a
player directly in in the repeater but
then we can do more we can start looking
at what happens if I replace the state
we have here by another state so here we
have another example and you can see
that the widget is going to pick up the
change on the state attribute and
because this stator field was propagated
from the kernel to the front end and
then on the front end we can pick up the
change and show the new state in real
time all right so we can also use this
kind of tools here to actually modify
the state in in in real time so here
using the notebook so for example we can
just say okay just display me half of
the items on the islands so now we are
going to restart reload the entire
island but it's half empty and we can
also use this kind of widget to just
build a state from scratch and make
maybe do some kind of experiment see how
people where people place their their
items on the screen and on the island so
for that we can just say for example
let's use position X 15 and then put all
of the items in a straight line so if we
execute this we see that they are indeed
coming up in a straight line completely
arbitrary we can do something a bit more
advanced and if we change that for
example not
fifteen but 25 then now we are using X
25 all right
so that's basically that's basically the
the kind of visualization you can make
when you start leveraging the entire
JavaScript ecosystem and the that was
the recap and in terms of applications
so as we saw it's quite a nice tool to
be able to actually see what's happened
what's happening so for example in the
case of the little puzzle let's say you
have an assignment for a student and
it's a university or whatever and you
don't want them to bother too much with
the visualization so you just okay here
is the widget here is how you can see if
whether your solution is good or not and
now it's time to implement your
algorithm so I think this is the kind of
thing we're starting to see already in
this whole JavaScript cluster if you
remember the map in the beginning where
we have interactivity using existing
JavaScript libraries but I think it's
it's really great for these kind of
applications and then yeah and then now
we are starting to look at actually
games written in in javascript in the
browser and in our case in repeaters so
we can there are tons of applications we
can do with this of course there is one
downside which is that you have to build
this whole visualization so in that in
that case it's implemented in an mix of
typescript and JavaScript so you have to
put the effort to actually create that
visualizations and as we saw here it was
really like for specific use case so of
course it's not like as generic as this
kind of bigger plot libraries that we
saw in in a beginning alright so there
are a bunch of references on the tuple
which has a lot of very very good work
already done you can really have a look
at that and of course if you have any
questions right now is the right time or
you can also ask them on Twitter github
or my website thank you for listening